[Music]
total work was a term coined by Joseph
pepper a lesser-known
German philosopher in the 20th century
and he was concerned that after world
war ii there would be a time of total
work by that i take him to mean that
work comes to be the center around which
the world turns the human beings start
to see themselves chiefly as workers and
the entirety of life becomes more and
more work or work like to see this we
can begin to examine a number of what I
might call tightening conditions so the
first condition would be the centrality
of work we come to think that work is
actually the center and everything else
begins to turn around it to see this
more clearly we can think about the fact
that we woke up to go to work today or
that we are going home from work today
that we are preparing for work that we
are preparing to leave work and this is
happening all the way around the world
meanwhile we're adjusting our schedules
the rest of our lives so that they are
turning about it so that would be the
first condition the second condition is
subordination that everything else in
life comes to seem as if its subordinate
to and to be put in the service of work
we can think of sleeping right the the
ideas that we wish to sleep well today
in order to be focused and prepared for
work and that when we're at work we wish
to be as productive as possible so sleep
becomes that which is an instrument in
the service of productivity and we can
play that game with all sorts of
different instances the third condition
is the resemblance claim it seems as if
everything else in life comes to
resemble work more and more so you can
think of on a day off you're wanting to
be as productive as possible thinking
about how much you got done
you can begin to think about all the
ways in which you plan and schedule time
with children the the terms that begin
to mark out our lives even we're not
actually working sound more and more
work like in the last condition I think
is the the most intense and that's what
I might call cultural forgetfulness
we've come to almost forget that there
was a time in which work was not the
center of the world but there are other
ways of life that precede the modern
world in which work was a part of life
that was not the focus of life we forget
that that's still true today with other
cultures some other cultures and we
forget that there could actually be a
time when work would not be that around
which the rest of the world turns so
what I'm not claiming is that we have
actually achieved total work what I'm
claiming rather is that we are in the
verge of doing so and then indeed we
should be grateful that we have yet to
arrive at I'm a dystopian time when work
is total well suppose there were to come
to pass universal basic income and
suppose the sake of argument that that
were sufficient to meet our material
needs that is those concerned with
having enough food proper shelter
sufficient warmth sufficient coldness
and like so that it was enough as one
philosopher Harry Frankfurt calls it to
be a doctrine of sufficiency
so suppose basic income allowed us all
to have enough then once again I think
we would need to think about what we
would do were there with ourselves
Aristotle and the politics says really
quite famously that we we non leisure in
order to have leisure and that was the
way that it would be translated we
non-lead in or to have leisure the
question is how are we going to dwell in
our leisure and I think we've been
educated to a point at which we really
don't know how to answer that question
people I think are struck by a very
difficult condition which is a medieval
condition called acedia
a CD is hard to translate but it means
that there's a restlessness of spirit an
inability to be still or quiet and being
instead when you watch people you see
time and time again that they're
actually quite Restless they can't do
well with what they're doing they can't
so easily pay attention I don't think
that that's the result of technology but
I think that the technology has
exacerbated that condition so the the
trouble with a lot of policy statements
associated with universal basic income
is not the particular x' not the
particular policy statements themselves
it's rather the philosophical question
how are we going to actually occupy
ourselves how are we going to live
individually in a community if we don't
have work as that which is governing
each of our days let alone the totality
of our lives
there are three common objections that
are made to the argument that we've
entered a time that is on the verge of
total work the first objection is to say
that well certainly we have to meet our
basic needs and it is through work that
we do so and I would I would grant that
claim that is I'm not actually arguing
against the idea that work would play
some role in our lives some rolled
during a waking hours some role during
the unfolding of our life what I'm
objecting to is the idea that it becomes
everything the be-all and end-all so
once we go past the point of meaning our
own material needs our own ability to
survive then we've gotten into trouble
I'm arguing the the second misconception
is that people commonly think that what
I'm arguing for is work-life balance and
I'm not actually arguing for that that
is I think the idea work-life balance is
actually something that total work takes
up and enjoys operating with meaning if
you actually put work on one side and
the rest of life on the other and claim
that work is as
important as love and joy and and
religious worship and philosophical
investigations and an investigation of
the cosmos if you really think that that
everything in life is is as valuable as
work than I think that's also a matter
to reconsider
it's rather these other matters are
actually more important than the value
we Accord to work and the third
misconception is that I'm just arguing
against overwork and I don't think
that's really what I'm up to
I think the overwork actually is a local
manifestation of total work instead I
think it's the case that surely we
wouldn't probably work as much if we
care less about work that is certainly
true but I think the overwork is simply
a red herring a way of trying to deflect
attention from the ways in which in our
ordinary everyday lives work has come to
matter to us so deeply we think that
there are simply a few people out there
who are working far too much and we
pathologize them pathologize saying that
they are just workaholics they care too
much but we've yet to actually
investigate the ways in which that's
true for us as well
[Music]
you